[Musica]
buon pomeriggio la storia che vi
racconto è una storia che guarda a spazi
di rinascita partendo da tre grandi
ambiti quello della cultura
dell'agricoltura in qualche maniera e ne
vedremo alcuni esempi quello della cura
e quello della cultura
nel farlo guarderemo tanti esempi nati
da giovani di questo territorio e spesso
sperimentate realizzati in questo
territorio che ci permetteranno di
guardare a nuovi concetti di spazi
digitali e soprattutto di spazi
intelligenti cosa sia la l'intelligenza
artificiale l'ha detto benissimo de
lucchi poco fa è questo questa
collaborazione
questa alleanza tra uomo e macchina è
una collaborazione della quale prendere
pregi non aver paura dei difetti e
guardare alle tante idee che nascono
attorno a tutto questo è un po lo scopo
di questo racconto è proprio quello è
proprio quello di raccontare le tante
idee che tanti ragazzi del nostro
territorio hanno in questo e lo faremo
guardando proprio a questo territorio
non vogliamo che il nostro territorio
del futuro sia molto diverso da questo
vogliamo che dentro questo territorio ci
siano componenti intelligenti ci siano
componenti che in qualche maniera ci
aiutino a guardare in maniera ottimista
una rinascita e dentro questi territori
vogliamo che le componenti intelligenti
e le idee e le idee nascano da luoghi di
confronto come questo luogo di confronto
in cui i giovani abbiano la possibilità
di esprimere il loro grandissimo
potenziale
tutte le idee che ci raccontiamo sono
idee nate da ragazzi di questo
territorio qualche ballata più al nord a
sud di tolentino e iniziamo proprio dall
agricoltura di precisione
questi sono i nostri droni sono droni
piccoli molto poco costosi che viaggiano
sopra piccoli terreni e permettono
all'agricoltore di utilizzare fonti
informative molto più alte
qui siamo ad agugliano voliamo sopra
agugliano e quella
piccolo elicottero porta con sé dei
sensori dei piccoli occhi come quelli
che vedete è quei piccoli occhi hanno
capacità di vista multispettrale o
iperspettrale ci permettono di guardare
fuori dal visibile e ci permettono di
comprendere da un semplice sorvolo
quanto bisogno aq d'acqua a quel terreno
quanto bisogno del di azoto a quel
terreno quelle mappe colorate quelle
mappe semantiche vengono elaborate da un
algoritmo nato da ragazzi come adriano
come michele come tanti che provengono e
crescono nelle nostre scuole nelle
nostre università nei nostri territori
quella mappa permette all'agronomo di
scegliere la maniera con cui far
crescere quei terreni e quella mappa
permette anche di essere sostenibili
sostenibili in tutte le accezioni
possibili sostenibili a livello
ambientale sostenibile a livello
economico e speriamo che quella mappa
permetta anche di utilizzare sul
piccolissimo dei nostri territori delle
nostre aree interne
tanta tecnologia tanta intelligenza
artificiale dentro quell alleanza di cui
parlava lo stesso vale se guardiamo a un
allevamento e anche qui le idee dei
ragazzi le tante ricerche portate avanti
nel mondo della robotica
dell'automazione sempre utilizzando una
qualche camera che cerchi di simulare il
nostro meraviglioso occhio permette a
questo piccolo allevamento che vedete a
pochissimi esemplari di essere
completamente automatizzato di nuovo una
testa che nasce nel territorio per
guardare al mondo per arrivare poi in
olanda negli stati uniti a portare
queste idee in giro per il mondo
quei robot gestiscono completamente
quell'allevamento puliscono prendono il
latte mungono gestiscono tutto il cibo e
quei robot lo fanno utilizzando e
sgravando il nostro allevatore di
grandissime lavori manuali lo fanno non
perdendo la poesia perché la poesia
cambia e l'abbiamo ascoltato la musica
cambia e probabilmente i nostri ragazzi
che scrivono algoritmi di intelligenza
artificiale ci piace anche immaginarli
come moderni poeti cambia per permettere
una gestione di nuovo sostenibile di
tutto quello che vediamo e questo vale
anche se ci spostiamo poi nello jesino e
guardiamo come delle altre idee
permettono di gestire una cantina e
tutta la parte di produzione delle uve
in maniera di nuovo intelligente quelli
sono sistemi di supporto alle decisioni
dietro hanno sempre un algoritmo un
qualche sistema di intelligenza
artificiale che utilizza tanti dati e
quei tanti dati fanno da supporto l'uomo
l'uomo decide decide quale vino fare
quale combinazione fare ma lo fa dentro
quella alleanza con la macchina e quando
quel vino arriva in mano al consumatore
e anche questo è stato un interessante
esperimento di nuovo qualche vallata più
assurdo in questo caso il consumatore
può darci informazioni oggi raccogliamo
le applicazioni come queste i profili
sensoriali non è più il sommelier a dare
indicazioni su tutto ciò su tutti quelli
che sono i profumi i sensi del vino ma è
l'utente l'utente che giocando con
quella rotellina cpc da indicazioni ci
dice cosa prova e lo fa in maniera
diversa lo fa in cina in maniera diversa
rispetto all'italia
e lo fa negli stati uniti in california
maniera diversa rispetto alla danimarca
e anche questa analisi questa analisi di
dati ci permette di raccogliere di
cambiare le nostre produzioni avendo un
supporto non pensando che tutto il mondo
fruisca dei nostri meravigliosi mini
nella stessa maniera
da queste da questi esempi dobbiamo
ripensare un agricoltura del futuro
piccola delle nostre aree interne che
utilizzi questa alleanza come sua chiave
per il suo re start e se cambiamo ambito
e ci spostiamo nel mondo della cura
anche gli spazi e la cura oggi sono
spazi intelligenti questo che vedete a
che sa domo è il tetto sono le tante
iniziative che sono nate da territori
come questi per guardare al mondo e sono
le tante iniziative che devono
permetterci di ripensare in maniera
completamente diversa il modo con cui
disegni
negli spazi i territori delle nostre
aree interne hanno una percentuale di
anziani molto più alta della media e
quel modo con cui l'edilizia e i
dispositivi sono presenti all'interno
delle case sta cambiando completamente e
in questo cambiamento c'è una domotica
basata su l'uomo che permette in maniera
non invasiva di analizzare cadute di
misurare parametri d'italia e lo fa non
mettendo addosso nulla non rendendo
nulla di questo visibile lo fa dentro
una multidisciplinarietà che vede
ingegneri esperti intelligenza
artificiale architetti e designer
dialogare tra loro proprio come oggi
pomeriggio lo fa utilizzando di nuovo
idee e algoritmi che nascono dalla mente
in questo caso ad esempio di daniele che
può che con lia che ha poi con linee da
qui scrive i primi algoritmi di analisi
automatica delle cadute in tutto questo
scenario il il mondo degli spazi sicura
vede un altro mondo interessante il
dibattito delle aree interne quanti
ospedali avremo e dove li avremo ma in
realtà probabilmente anche qui dovremmo
immaginare nuovi spazi e intelligenti e
in questi nuovi spazi intelligenti
l'esempio che vedete un esempio
eccellente è un esempio di un'altra
delle eccellenze di questa area
siamo al salesi quella piccola culla è
una culla che oggi può essere
distribuita sul territorio che raccoglie
dati di bambini prematuri i super
piccoli che il professor carnielli cura
e li raccoglie in maniera distribuita di
malick che vuol dire tutto questo vuol
dire che possiamo avere quella con la
tolentino in qualsiasi altro punto delle
nostre aree in qualsiasi altro punto del
mondo
i dati vengono raccolti la culla cambia
completamente il suo concetto diventa
una culla che è del tutto non invasiva
utilizza un unico sensore con dentro
molta intelligenza per esempio che
vedete è un esempio che ci racconta di
come l'analisi del movimento di questi
bambini molto piccoli spesso pesano 400
500 600 grammi sono grandi più o meno
con la mia mano
sia determinante per permettere lo
sviluppo e molto ci dà molta
soddisfazione questi ragazzi salvano
vite di bambini appena nati
e lo fanno perché analizzando quel
movimento una di simmetria del movimento
è un indice di un possibile ictus che
quel meraviglioso cervello
appena arrivato nel mondo e capace di
iniziare a respirare ossigeno non riesce
a recuperare molto velocemente
a patto di conoscere quel dato a patto
di essere supportati da una macchina che
guarda 24 ore su 24 quel bambino e
questa macchina ripeto oggi non ha più
senso immaginarla racchiusa in un unico
spazio così come non ha senso immaginare
racchiusa in un unico spazio è tutto il
mondo dell'assistenza agli anziani
questi spazi poi diventano spazi della
cultura
abbiamo raccolto nuvole di punti e
immagini e scansioni di grandi spazi per
tanti anni ma oggi tutto quello che
raccogliamo può essere analizzato di
nuovo in tempo reale di nuovo da
algoritmi che apprendono da quegli spazi
questo è un esempio di nuovo un po più a
nord di tolentino ma questo esempio ci
racconta come oggi è possibile fare
analisi dei cambiamenti qualsiasi
martone che si sia spostato gli sovrana
lizzato in tempo reale qualsiasi
variazione che c'è stata e analizzata in
tempo reale ea partire da queste
scansioni si possono creare oggi con una
di nuova alleanza tra uomo e macchina
nuove forme di progettazione nuove forme
di ideazione forme che oggi ci
raccontano anche di quali sono le
caratteristiche di quel di quel
manufatto
d quali sono caratteristiche semantiche
quindi di nuovo ci danno mappe di
rischio mappe di pericoli di quelle aree
oppure possiamo immaginare altri
territori sensibili spazi che raccolgono
informazioni e che ridanno indietro
informazioni e in questo
immaginiamoci uno dei centri storici di
questo territorio in quel centro storico
e ci sono tanti bigon sono quei piccoli
oggetti che vedete disegnati lì in alto
e questi b con raccolgono informazioni
dei nostri cellulari e mettono
informazioni verso i nostri cellulari
per far cosa
in qualche maniera per influenzare il
nostro spostamento per suggerirci di
andare al di là piuttosto che dall'altra
parte e lo fanno anche per misurare dati
per misurare statistiche per cercare un
po di abbattere il famoso mito di 100
mila per gli organizzatori mille per la
questura lo fanno perché questa raccolta
dati ci permetta di pianificare meglio
di pianificare meglio eventi di
pianificare meglio spazi ed immaginare
che quegli spazi e quelle pietre che
prima abbiamo scansionato ora parlino
diano indicazioni e stimolino diversi
comportamenti all'interno dello spazio
stesso
questa è una realtà realizzata in questo
ambito che permette anche di tracciare i
movimenti di tracciare comportamenti
perché ci interessano i comportamenti
perché da quei comportamenti possiamo
anche individuare tutto ciò che è
anomalo tutti coloro che si spostano in
maniera anomala tutti coloro che possono
in qualche maniera costituire rischi per
i nostri spazi e dentro questi spazi
vive anche il mondo dei beni culturali
siamo a palazzo ducale siamo davanti ai
grandi capolavori qualche anno fa le
prime esperienze di realtà aumentata e
di scansioni ad altissima risoluzione
potete guardare quei dettagli a
risoluzione mai vista neanche visibile
davanti a quel quadro potete rendervi
conto di tutto questo e poi visitare
quello spazio visitarlo in due maniere
virtualmente dentro un'esperienza di
realtà virtuale oppure attraverso
un'esperienza di realtà aumentata
vuol dire che sono davanti a quel bene
culturale davanti a quel bene culturale
voglio interagire voglio scoprire voglio
guardare e tutto questo è un altro dei
punti da cui fare il nostro re start è
un altro dei punti su cui ragionare per
cercare insieme di immaginare nuovi
spazi della cultura nuovi spazi che sono
stati poco fa descritti in maniera
eccellente e che dentro hanno spesso
tanti sistemi intelligenti
oggi stiamo guardando come i bambini
guardano
ed è impressionante e guardare che la
generazione alfa abbia un approccio
completamente diverso dalla nostra
cerchi di scoprire simboli nascosti
porte semichiuse e abbia una curiosità e
questa curiosità e anche in puro il tema
con cui voglio arrivare verso una
conclusione questa curiosità ci racconta
della grandissima necessità di idee e di
uomini e appunto di curiosità cosa sono
quelle paroline storte che vedete lì
sopra che ne dite sono capaci ho sentito
ea cosa servono
giusto per capire se siamo uomini o
macchine ma in realtà ci se vi chiedessi
ma perché ce ne fanno compilare 2 per
essere più sicuri della prima domanda è
la prima risposta che di solito date in
realtà per essere più sicuri sarebbe
bastata una parola più lunga in realtà
ne compiliamo due perché partecipiamo
con la nostra meravigliosamente che non
sarà mai sostituito da nessuna macchina
ad un grande progetto di
digitalizzazione dei libri antichi
recaptcha prende un po di immagini né
che non sono comprensibili alla macchina
e le da noi affinché noi traduciamo
quella scritta following in un testo
digitale following non sapete però se è
la prima o la seconda parola e quindi
non potete tirare a caso quindi una
serve per capire se siamo uomini o
macchine e l'altra serve perché voi
state prestando la vostra
meravigliosamente a digitalizzare libri
antichi
certo dobbiamo essere curiosi se
qualcuno ci chiede di digitalizzare di
compilare due paroline dobbiamo sempre
chiederci perché è questa curiosità va
anche avanti
qui vi siano capitati cosa state facendo
si fa tesi con la testa
ma cosa stiamo facendo stiamo aiutando
il progetto google street view a
digitalizzare i numeri civici insegna in
giro per il mondo e lo facciamo perché
nessuna macchina è in grado di farlo al
posto nostro e lo facciamo prestando un
po del nostro cervello in realtà
facciamo ancora di più
anche questi immagino vi siano capitati
in questo caso poi state aiutando
l'algoritmo di apprendimento di
intelligenza artificiale a scovare
segnali perché perché vogliamo
addestrare le macchine del futuro
e perché le nostre macchine il futuro le
macchine dei nostri figli non saranno
guidate dai nostri figli ma guideranno i
nostri figli come per la culla del
salesi salveremo 12 persone al giorno
solo guardando all'italia immaginatele
quante altre guardando al mondo ma alla
base c'è il messaggio da cui siamo
partiti c'è un'alleanza tra l'uomo e la
macchina c'è un bisogno folle di idee e
di uomini curiosi uomini come quelli che
in qualche maniera oggi come dice sono
portato a chiacchierare e qui a
tolentino
grazie a tutti
[Applauso]